and firefighters in algeria have managed
to bring a series of forest fires under
control but not before they killed at
least 38 people and left hundreds more
with burns or respiratory problems
survivors are taking stock of the tragic
consequences and are asking why more
wasn't done to stop the flames
it was in this scorched bus that 12
people suffered their terrifying last
moments
as the flames of algeria's wildfires
drew closer they were suddenly
surrounded they couldn't get away in
time
the road was closed and there was no
escape you can see for yourself the fire
covered the whole region young children
were among the victims who died inside
the bus they died holding on to each
other
a wave of wildfires has swept through
algeria's forests killing dozens and
injuring hundreds of others
blistering temperatures of up to 48
degrees celsius have turned large areas
into a tinderbox climate change is
turning this into an annual event
just last year over a hundred people
lost their lives in massive wildfires
despite this many algerians feel that
lessons from that disaster were not
learned authorities have been accused of
not being prepared and lacking
firefighting aircraft
one contract to buy such aircraft from
spain was torn up over a diplomatic
dispute in june
people died and nobody came
where are the planes to combat the fires
children and babies died here they went
to god
we had to wait three hours for help to
arrive
prime minister ayman bin abdulrahman
assured victims and their families that
the state would support them and said
the government had ordered four new
firefighting aircraft
with the climate heating up algeria will
no doubt face catastrophic wildfires
again
the question that remains is if they'll
be prepared for them